we used to like terrorize people at
school there's one time we beat up this
girl really bad and like the cops got
involved and they're like oh you guys
can go to jail or like why we're only
like normally 13 you know my mom was
pissed
you're not going anywhere near be like
these normals in my year like I am one
and you don't know like I can't raise e
to be like this but they where are you
though like but where are you haven't
been here you know we've been doing this
it was just so cry for attention you
know miss my mom I was 13 years old and
when I initially started hanging out
with my gang member friend you want to
say my homies you don't think that
they're bad people you think they're
cool because they were you know we were
the people getting in trouble and it was
fun you know I had a lot of fun back
then but like do I regret some of the
things I did the people yeah
my mom works a lot when we were little
and she left me home with my brothers
even better I got to have health buddies
come home whenever I wanted mom was
never around and I'm not saying that my
mom was a bad mom because my mom was the
best mom that she could be at that time
I love my mom to death and my mom is
being them on that I count right now the
first time I lost my kids I was with my
youngest sons that I was really really
heavily into math just newly into this
relationship and he went to the store to
go steal candy bars to big boxes of
candy bars and my vehicle they follow
him out to the car the car doesn't start
so he leaves my car there and of course
they take the plate number down and the
cops show up at my house the hours later
and a long story short there's
paraphernalia in the home I get arrested
for child endangerment my children get
detained I went through hell and high
water to pick up my kids back I ended up
getting my kids back and I got
everything I wanted
you know I screwed it up again right I
stayed in that relationship and
continued to get abused
[Applause]
and I lost my children and because of
their I mean at that point in time I was
literally going to jail every month
nobody was there literally nobody was
there but my mom you say these people
are your homies and they're gonna die
for you but they're they can't even
write you a letter or like put money on
your books say hey how you doing come
busy you you know nothing that's what I
don't understand there wasn't really a
process for me like a guy said I just
kind of fade it away and I just
disappeared you know what I mean and I
feel like a lot of people kind of do
that but there's a lot of people that
call it the hard way
I never seen it happen but I've heard of
it happening
[Music]
[Music]
I was in a sober-living and I just got
my other kids back like I needed a job
two three interviews and think I'm hired
and then they'll run my record then it's
over like I won't get a callback it's
this ferjeen you know I could already
know what it was you know like I just
gotta agile not that long ago it makes
you feel like a piece of [ __ ] like but
what you do like your records right
there for everybody to read and you
can't really lie about it all you can do
is explain yourself like hey I'm trying
to be a better person but they don't
really want to hear that I see what's on
black and white I had to be an example
to my brothers and I ended up being the
example of what not to be I was the only
one out of all my mom's kids that didn't
graduate high school I was the only one
out of all my mom's kids to get arrested
and have a record like I did to get all
my kids taken away from me to you know
just end up the way I did and to end up
getting involved in gangs and constantly
be incarcerated go to rehab you know
it's not nothing I'm proud of but you
know all I can do is just be a better
person today you know just be somebody
that she would want me to be I know for
a fact that people that are trying to
leave gangs are trying to get clean or
just looking for that one chance to make
an honest living or do something
positive with their life and they're not
goodnight you know all this is what's on
black and white and what's on their
record oh you have a felony or you have
a misdemeanor no you're just a criminal
and like you go to places like homeboy
you're not the worst thing that you've
ever done when she is a gang
intervention program I was four previous
incarcerated men one
that just get out of prison or jail try
to help them see a different way of life
and help them you rehabilitated homeboy
Industries means family to me
it is family to me it means a second
chance to me I've gotten an amazing job
at a money management firm everybody in
that firm knows everything about me and
still encourages me to win and it's just
an awesome feeling and just to be it to
be accepted in a industry like that you
know like corporate America and people
see the tattoos and they don't even trip
on it you know I still do it Terrance
if I can go back and tell myself at my
lowest point I'm something encouraging
I've had some really really dark moments
I remember they're like human points to
worry I didn't want to be around but I
was like too scared to even kill myself
you know hold on tight yeah be patient
with myself because I can be very
difficult but patience has always helped
me through
I can't wait to fall asleep
ize a heavy breathless D
all's Quiet industry
leave the worries that I can
I'll be tree
I'll be tree
tonight
I'll be dreaming
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part